[Musique]
c'est
ah oui charles
avant bien bas
[Musique]
bonsoir vous avez peut-être reconnu alan
parsons project
1985 à monia avenue je vais tenter de
vous convaincre ce soir que cela est
peut-être en train de devenir une
réalité
je m'appelle christine du professeur à
l'université de lyon mon domaine
d'expertisé la combustion et tout
particulièrement la combustion dans les
moteurs automobiles
mon avenir de chercheurs est totalement
compromis la france a décidé de bannir
le moteur thermique en 2035 seuls les
véhicules électriques seront mises à la
vente
j'avais deux possibilités
soit me dire chouette je vais partir en
retraite anticipée ou soit déprimé
pourtant j'ai choisi de venir vous
parler ce soir et je n'ai pas l'air si
déprimée
énergie pollution
environnement réchauffement climatique
dérèglement climatique ces mots à nous
assaillent de par les médias les réseaux
sociaux
l'europe a décidé
ce 14 juillet d'être le premier
continent à atteindre la neutralité en
carbone en 2050 dans le pacte vers le
green deal
pour cela nous allons être en plein
transition énergétique
certains pensent que nous vivons une
période
déprimante sans avenir pour nos enfants
moi je suis convaincu qu elle est
passionnante des transitions
énergétiques
nous en avons vécu plusieurs de par le
passé vive le charmant et la machine à
vapeur vive le pétrole vive l'automobile
1974 le premier choc pétrolier
l'occident se prend en pleine poire
le pouvoir économique des ressources
énergétiques en france on nous demande
d'éteindre nos lumières vers 23 heures
où notre télévision mais surtout
certains d'entre vous se rappellent on
nous assomme d'un super slogan en france
on n'a pas de pétrole mais on a des
idées et vive l'électricité est
nucléaire
alors que pouvons nous faire pour
réussir ce nouveau challenge dans lequel
s'est engagé l'europe
première action devenir sobre consommer
moins consommer mieux tous à l'échelle
locale nous pouvons y contribuer
à l'échelle nationale cela se complique
un peu les enjeux politico économico
brouillaud les actions
à l'échelle internationale notre
population ne cesse de croître
nous espérons que tout ce que chacun
pourront avoir accès à l'énergie à la
nourriture à l'eau aux nouveaux moyens
de communication notre consommation
énergétique ne va cesser de croître
deuxième action augmenter le rendement
de nos installations
améliorer l'efficacité bien sûr nous
devons agir dans ce sens mais je pense
que la technologie et la thermodynamique
ou parfois des limites
troisième action faisons-le à cette
transition énergétique
utilisons les énergies vertes et
renouvelables
que savons nous de ces énergies
elles sont infinies inépuisable alors
oui donc on aura du soleil et une
planète
elles n'ont pas d'impact co2
combien coûte t elle pouvons-nous les
recycler
ils sont leur durée de vie sur les 4000
éoliennes actuellement installés en
france
1500 doivent être démantelés d'ici 2030
le recyclage n'avait pas été prévu en
allemagne pour le moment on les enfouis
dans le sol
troisième action
posons nous réfléchissons
faisant cette transition utilisons
pleinement des énergies renouvelables
nous en étions là
nous en étions là utilisant pleinement
les énergies renouvelables bien sûr
quelle est leur spécificité autres elles
sont
fugitive
inter me tente
notre consommation tout au long d'une
journée un grand pic le matin de 6h à 9h
un grand pic le soir de 18h à 21h et un
minimum le midi pourtant le soleil y
brille au beau fixe tout au long de
l'année c'est à peu près la même chose
nous consommons un maximum de janvier à
mars
d'octobre à descendre avec un minima
durant l'été et nous savons tous que le
soleil est à son apogée
en clair les énergies renouvelables ne
sont jamais là quand on en a besoin
comment allons nous faire pour utiliser
pleinement ces énergies
alors des solutions sont en cours de
développement existent peut-être déjà la
première qui nous vient à l'esprit
stockons c'est électricité produits
quand on en a pas besoin dans des
batteries
imaginons en moins de notre planète sera
remplie de batterie et comment allons
nous faire pour le lithium et quelle est
leur durée de vie et comment allons-nous
les recycler
une autre solution et si on utiliser
cette électricité disponible pour
remonter l'eau dans les barrages et
quand nous avons besoin de lui mais
notre lumière or nous lâchons l'eau et
récupérons électricité via notre turbine
cela existe déjà en france par exemple
nous avons le barrage de grand maison en
isère en deux minutes nous récupérons
autant d'électricité que celle produite
par deux réacteurs nucléaires cette
solution est très alléchante mais elle
est un peu lié à la géographie la
géologie de notre territoire
notre ex solutions sont aussi encore en
cours de développement
celle qui m'intéresse aujourd'hui je
vais l'illustré par trois objets que je
vous ai amené tout d'abord ma petite
éolienne pour représenter mon énergie
verte et puis une bouteille d'eau
qu'elle peut-il être le lien entre une
éolienne et l'eau pire encore j'ai amené
une bouteille très étrange de l'ammoniac
certains l'utilisent parfois comme
produits ménagers on sait surtout que
c'est toxique que ça brûle la peau qu'il
faut éviter de lyne hallé que c'est une
odeur pas du tout agréable et même si on
n'en reversent un peu sur du métal qui
contient du cuivre savas oxydé
voilà ma devinette qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire de ces trois objets et bien voilà
je prends l'électricité qui est fabriqué
par mon éolienne
jules utilise dans un électrolyseur
l'électrolyseur en clair je met de l'eau
avec cette électricité je vais casser la
molécule d'eau h2o et je vais pouvoir
extraire l'hydrogène h2 vous avez
certainement entendu parler d'hydrogène
la france est partie dans la fabuleuse
aventure de l'hydrogène notre nouveau
slogan hydrogène dans notre territoire
alors l'hydrogène c'est bien bien sûr
ça quelques petits inconvénients
ça une faible densité énergétique
pour le stocker le transporter on est
obligé de le préciser 350 bar 700 bars
ou de le refroidir à 250 degrés c'est
une si petite molécule qu'elle peut
s'infiltrer partout dans tous les
matériaux
enfin l'hydrogène a tendance à
s'enflammer facilement
d'autres ont pensé à une molécule
beaucoup plus intéressante la moe niaque
j'ai triché un petit peu ce n'est pas de
l'ammoniac a que ça à un mot n'y a
qu'avec un
cnh
3h tient l'hydrogène l'idée est simple
on utilise l'ammoniac comme stocker et
transporter d'hydrogène
l'ammoniaque a plusieurs avantages c'est
le deuxième produit chimique
transportés à travers le monde on le
transporte en camion en train en bateau
même les us et la russie ont des papes
line d'ammoniac
cette molécule est énormément utilisé
sur notre planète évidemment pour
l'agriculture mais aussi pour
l'industrie chimique la réfrigération
alimentaires et même thomas pesquet
notre astronautes l'a utilisé sur la
station spatiale internationale
puisque c'est un produit utilisé en
climatisation
enfin l'ammoniac à une densité
énergétique deux fois plus élevé qu
l'hydrogène pas besoin de le préciser à
700 bars 9 bars il est déjà en phase
liquide ou moins 25 degrés il est aussi
en phase liquide
contrairement à son petit cousin
l'hydrogène
l'ammoniaque lui résiste fortement à
l'inflammation
le japon a eu une super idée ils ont
commencé leur transition énergétique
bien à vendre l'idée est très simple le
japon petit pays grande densité de
population 0 ressources énergétiques
l'australie son voisin grands pays
faible densité de population
de nombreuses ressources énergétiques
l'éolien le solaire l'hydraulique la
géothermie
l'idée est très simple
l'australie va produire de l'ammoniaque
qui sera acheminé par bateau jusqu'au
japon
évidemment au départ le japon avait
prévu de recasser cette molécule et nash
trois pour récupérer ce qu'il contient
en hydrogène mais n'y at il pas des
moyens plus efficaces et cie ont brûlé
directement l'ammoniac
cette idée n'est pas récente retournons
80 ans en arrière la seconde guerre
mondiale rupture de carburant une flotte
de bus belge mais dans ses moteurs un
mélange d'ammoniac et de gaz aux yeux
cela marche il faut plusieurs kilomètres
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres
plusieurs milliers de kilomètres
à orléans l'histoire a commencé
il ya cinq ans quand l'un de mes
collègues belges encore et c'est pas une
histoire belge vous le promets c'est pas
une blague est venu nous voir en nous
disant mais christine et si tu mettais
de l'ammoniaque dans ses moteurs
automobiles
je me disais ce n'est pas possible ça ne
peut pas brûler eh bien si
depuis cinq ans je suis de plus en plus
passionné brûlé l'ammoniac c'est pas si
simple c'est ce que j'avais dit souvent
on est obligés demander de l'aide à son
cousin l'hydrogène
des réalisations existent de par le
monde en développement des tracteurs
john deere en amérique brûle avec un
mélange d'ammoniac et d'hydrogène en
toscane des engins pour nettoyer les
trottoirs brûle aussi avec ce même
mélange
faire de la recherche sur la combustion
de l'ammoniac c'est par ce yo nan
pourquoi parce qu'il faut maîtriser
cette combustion augmenter les
rendements et finalement il faut aussi
éviter les émissions polluantes n
h30 contenu en carbone pas d'empreintes
et environnementale pour la combustion
de l'ammoniac mais il peut y avoir des
émissions de nox et surtout je n'ai pas
oublié l'ammoniac est toxique il faut
absolument que nous évitons les fuite
d'ammoniac
vous voyez je suis de plus en plus
passionné je ne partirai pas en retraite
anticipée même l'office maritime
international qui a écrit pour la
première fois sa feuille de route pour
décarbonés ce secteur amy l'ammoniac
comme l'un des combustibles de demain
pour alimenter les navires
des applications il y en a de nombreuses
peut-être que je ne verrai jamais la
monaque dans un nom notre voiture mais
pourquoi pas dans des flottes captives
kafka petit kft un captive dans des
moteurs électrogènes pour produire de
l'électricité
il faudra plus de 40 ans après la moigne
avenue d'alan parsons project pour que
cela devienne une réalité
comme le disait cette grande dame
qu'elle simone veil ne redoutons pas à
l'avenir
je suis confiante
nous réussirons tous cette nouvelle
transition énergétique
merci
[Applaudissements]